so here's a thought right communication
is an attempt at a transgression it's an
attempt at crossing over and entering
the mind of the other or rather bringing
the other into one's own mind
communication is an attempt at a kind of
inter subjective coherence right it's a
it's a means to achieve a shared
mutuality to enter an intersubjective
space together and I think that language
is one way to tell each other what we
mean so to speak but when language
becomes visual right then we can show
you what we mean and one of the things
that Terence Mckenna the psychedelic
philosopher talks about is that virtual
reality technologies allow us to turn
our minds inside out of the very same
ways that cave paintings early art
pottery poetry allows us to turn our
interior world into something that can
be visibly beheld language can be seen I
can show you what I mean and new
technological paintbrushes magic mirrors
electronic devices camera lenses like
this further extend this capacity to
objectify our inner world to take the
inside and make it the outside to show
you what I mean I can record this video
I can play it for you and I can be over
here with you beside myself showing you
what I mean and and ultimately the
desire of achieving this is is is then
to feel close to the other person to
bond to be able to share that hinting
recognition to have that cosmic link to
know that we are both experiencing the
same thing at the same time and you feel
less alone and you feel recognition
again to say that again and it's a
powerful thing
right to show each other what we mean
and I think that's the future of
communication technology to further
extend this capacity this linguistic
desire to meld Minds together